[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
marc fesneau bonjour là bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ministre
délégué chargé des relations avec le
parlement et de la participation
citoyenne on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview au
partenariat sous presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane
vernet bonjour stéphane bonjour ulti
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france on commence bien sûr marc
fesneau par les sénatoriales qui ont
lieu dimanche qu'elle le enseignement
principal quelles leçons vous retenez
vous de ce scrutin ont peut-être
plusieurs leçons la première se situe
d'ailleurs attendu en tout cas pour ce
qui nous concerne une forme de stabilité
au sénat mais on a toujours vu ce
mouvement-là au sénat est une chambre
la haute assemblée est une une assemblée
qui est plutôt stable parce que le corps
électoral est plutôt stable il ya pas de
grands mouvements donc ça c'est un
premier élément dans les données
générales et les équilibres généraux
deuxième élément signalé pour ce qui est
de ceux qui se présentaient sous
différentes étiquettes mais en tout cas
qui étaient plutôt en soutien de la
majorité contrairement à ce qui avait
été annoncé parfois je vais avec avec
joie pour certains sur certains plateaux
le fait que le groupe en marche voit ses
soucis position consolidée j'aurais
quand même saluer au passage la victoire
de françois patriat que tout le monde
n'attendait pas la victoire des deux
ministres le corps nu et lemoine et un
certain nombre de territoires
je pense à patricia habchi linge et je
pense à michel canevet ou le deuxième de
liste vient du groupe et l'hérault m on
a pu voir une forme d'ancrage et puis
des résultats au fond on va pas la
question n'est pas de savoir qui a gagné
qui a perduré bien que la majorité est
assez stable on voit bien que là aussi
quand il ya eu des candidats qui étaient
assez implanté les scores même s'ils
n'ont pas donné forcément des résultats
escomptés c'est à dire la victoire d'un
sénateur d'une sénatrice un ancrage
territorial qui c'est qui commence à
s'amorcer je pense aux bouches du rhône
où le candidat soutenu par la majorité
présidentielle est à deux doigts de
faire le siège je pense à jean pierre
cubertafon du modem en dordogne ou à 20
voies près il il manque d'être élu
sénateur donc c'est intéressant de
regarder de que là où il ya eu une forme
d'union et de une forme d'ancrage
finalement les résultats sont plutôt
rendez vous était le deuxième fait sans
doute à noter c'est mais c'était attendu
là aussi d'une certaine façon ce qui
était moins attendu c'était le groupe en
marche soit plutôt plus solide que ce
qui est qu est ce qui a été dit et de
ses démarrages ans d'un groupe
écologiste
mais là c'était plutôt attendue compte
tenu de ce qu'avait été les épisodes
électoraux du soulagement dans la
majorité présidentielle dimanche soir de
voir que finalement le groupe en marche
se maintenait à peu près du soulagement
non on était plutôt raisonnablement
confiant on va dire ça comme ça sur
l'idée alors après vous savez le sort
des urnes pour l'avoir vu à plusieurs
reprises dans ma vie politique faut
toujours être prudent
donc c'est pas une forme de soulagement
mais en tout cas c'était une
confirmation de ce que nous pensions est
ce que nous sentions mais après les
électeurs sont souvent et parfois on a
des surprises bonnes ou mauvaises
oui vous êtes quand même abusé entre
guillemets faut faire un peu peur dans
cette élection il y avait dans les
messages et les pâtes les commentateurs
ou les opposants à la république en
marche la majorité présidentielle qui
prédisaient une débat qu'il y avait
aussi des gens au sein de vos propres
rangs qui était un peu inquiet de voir
le matin en se disant que après les
municipales
après ce qui vous est arrivé aux
municipales en toute logique ça pouvait
mal se passer
oui mais il ya moi il ya quand même
logique implacable il y avait très peu
d'élus du modem ou de la république en
marche avant les municipales il y en a
mécaniquement plus après les municipales
même si les municipales n'ont pas été
couronnées de succès donc mécaniquement
il devait y avoir quelque chose de
consolider est ce que certains
nourrissait des inquiétudes oui parce
que voyez bien le dynamique qui sont à
l'oeuvre et parfois un certain nombre de
candidats qui ont du camp du batailler
défendre les positions du gouvernement
ce qui n'est pas toujours facile et qui
ont le qu'il en fallait beaucoup de
courage je trouve et le les victoires de
sébastien lecornu de jean-baptiste
lemoyne elles ont aussi fait la
différence le fait d'avoir des ministres
impliqués dans le dans l'élection ça a
pesé à la fois comme ministre mais au
fond ce qui fait leur élection c'est
leur ancrage local sébastien et jean
baptiste sont des ministres ancré
territorialement depuis longtemps et
durablement et c'est ça aussi qu'on
reconnaît les grands électeurs
il peut arriver qu'on soit ministre et
qu'on soit battue et il peut arriver que
étant très ancré dans sois élu donc
c'est pas forcément la feue la fonction
de ministre qui fait qu'on est élu ça
peut parfois même être un handicap est
justement est ce plutôt l'ancrage que ça
n'a pas été un handicap pour sébastien
lecornu il n'a fait qu'un siège servait
mouret son concurrent non je ne suis pas
dupe les deux autres sièges et c'est ce
qu'il a payé son étiquette de mini
on pourrait dire ça et en même temps
françois patriat était lui et pour le
coup n'était pas ministre mais il était
très étiquetés pour le coup une forme de
solennité courage qu'il faut saluer
apprécier les équations locales qui font
les le score final faut pas en tirer des
éléments trop compliqué je crois bon et
c'est aussi la droite qui ce qui se
renforce à nouveau si c'était encore
possibles au sénat
c'est aussi simple les enseignements de
ce scrutin vous vous êtes face à des
républicains qui sont très très ancré
dans cette institution
oui mais au final qu'à mais là c'était
déjà le cas ça n'est pas une grande
nouveauté je rappelle qu'il ya un seul
épisode où la majorité sénatoriale et ça
a duré trois ans n'était pas diront
disons nous dirons disons le sur le
flanc droit de l'échiquier politique
donc a pas de nouveauté il n'y a pas de
bouleversement de ce point de vue là
comme vous le savez les le gouvernement
et moi-même on travaille avec le sénat
parce que c'est la deuxième chambre je
trouve que les apports qui sont fait
d'ailleurs dans leur travail législatif
sont souvent significatif
il arrive aussi parfois même
régulièrement qu'on ne soit pas en
accord avec le sénat mais c'est bien en
démocratie que le pluralisme s'exprime
donc il ya une donnée qui procède des
élections qui ont eu lieu dimanche le du
renouvellement de la moitié du sénat et
on va travailler avec cette donnée c'est
françois patriat qui dit que le sénat
est une épine dans le pied de malko de
de macron est ce que c'est une si bonne
nouvelle que ça pour la majorité
ce renforcement de la droite et du
centre à quelques mois de la
présidentielle
regardez alors moi je vais pas faire le
tri je travaille avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires ce que je suis mise des
relations avec le parlement il ya des
gens qui manifestement sont plus proches
je pas sûr que dans tous les groupes
qu'on soit aussi homogène que ça en
disant tout ça est très opposée où tout
ça est très favorable je pense que dans
les groupes i un certain nombre de gens
qui ont pu manifester d'ailleurs à
l'occasion de vote sur des textes ou à
l'occasion de vote de confiance
une file de rappeler les différents
épisodes à l'occasion du vote sur le
projet de déconfinement qui ont pu
manifester une forme de responsabilité
qui était à la fois qui se vivait plutôt
comme dans l'opposition mais qui au fond
sur un certain nombre de sujets
essentiels ont pu donner le sentiment
est montré qu'il était plutôt à essayer
de construire des choses et cette maison
pardonnez moi ce terme est une maison
qui est plutôt constructive souvent dans
l'or il ya des moments d'opposition
assez rude cette agréable pour personne
en particulier pas pour le ministre des
relations avec le parlement
mais quand vous regardez le très haut
taux de commission mixte paritaire
conclusive on voit bien qu'il ya du
travail qui peut se faire donc au delà
des caricatures parfois qu'on pose sur
la table et du disp s2 bloc homogène qui
viendraient s'opposer moi je parle je ne
partage pas le sentiment que ça soit
forcément un écueil insurmontable la
preuve en est sur un certain nombre de
textes on a pu trouver des voies de
compromis vous êtes en train de nous
dire vous voyez le sénat contre 1 comme
un contre-pouvoir et non pas comme un
anti pouvoir pour reprendre une formule
chère à gérard larcher
mais tu ne s'ouvrent oui oui je ne
céderai c'est après adam qui libre dans
le pouvoir et sa natte ça a toujours été
un point de killing d'un pouvoir et donc
de contre-pouvoir y compris même quand
le sénat était aligné avec la majorité
assemblée nationale j'ai connu des
périodes où les l'assemblée et le sénat
étaient alignés mais le sénat ne portait
pas les mêmes messages et les mêmes
regards sur le projet d'un équilibre
c'est un point d'équilibré l'itif dès
lors qu'il ne s'érige pas je crois que
c'est la volonté du président larcher en
anti pouvoir c'est à dire quelque chose
qui par nature viennent s'opposer au
gouvernement place quel que soit le
gouvernement en place je pense qu'il est
dans son rôle
cécilia deux chambres c'est bien pour ça
c'est pour quelque chose qui soit 2 lors
de l' équilibre entre l'assemblée
nationale et sénat et au fond c'est
assez indépendant des étiquettes pour
moi c est structurellement le sénat
travaille différemment un regard
différent et institutionnellement il n'a
pas exactement les mêmes fonctions que
l'assemblée nationale il est moins
d'ailleurs et c'est une chance nous
semble utile soumis à l'air du temps
à l'ère de de la 2d chaîne d'info en
direct à l'ère de twitter et de facebook
et légiférer sans cette pression là
c'est une grande chance en vous venez de
parler des étiquettes est ce que vous
pouvez nous faire une petite leçon de
choses assez rapide qu'est ce qui va se
passer à la demande et les chômeurs
composition des groupes qu'ils valent et
avec qui non mais il m'appartient pas
d'alors pour le commencement pénis des
relations avec le parlement vous m
mettriez en porte-à-faux de m'immiscer
dans la vie des groupes
ce que je vois et ça rejoint ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est qu'il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui au qui ont
plutôt le sentiment que la politique est
menée par le gouvernement va dans le bon
sens ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont
totalement aligné le doigt sur la
couture du pantalon mais c'est pas ce
qui est demandé un parlementaire à
l'assemblée d'ailleurs comme au sénat
la seule question c'est que puisse
identifier ces gens là après ils sont
dans des groupes parfois qui ont qui
alors en leur sein en dsd comment
dirais-je des origines différentes ou
des regards différents sur la politique
gouvernementale après moi je ne rentre
pas directement cette question sur les
sénateurs modem
le couple la république en marche qui
veut s'élargir qui veut justement
dépasser les étiquettes qui va
d'ailleurs changer de nom pour ne plus
appeler la république en marche est ce
que pour vous les sénateurs modem
doivent rejoindre suis pas sûr que ce
soit une question groupe alors moi je
pense que tout ce qui permet de mettre
du lien et du liant et c'est pas
aujourd'hui que je le dis je l'avais dit
quand je suis arrivé en fonction donc
tout ce qui permet de mettre du liant et
du lien dans ce qui est ce qu'on appelle
désormais la maison commune c'est à dire
les gens qui viennent plutôt d'agir les
gens qui viennent plutôt du modem les
gens qui viennent évidemment la
république en marche et une bonne
nouvelle la forme que ça prend n'est pas
un sujet à ce stade majeur il faut en
tout cas que s'identifient ce qui sur un
certain nombre de sujets peuvent se
rassembler pour pour porter ce que nous
portons en termes de réformes et les
sénateurs modem souveraine manger les
sénateurs comme tous les parlementaires
ils sont assez soucieux de leur
indépendance et le sénat est assez
soucieux de son indépendance je ne viens
pas mais me céni donnaient des ordres ça
quand même un ton sens pour quand bien
même je pourrais leur donner un avis le
jour où on me le demande on ça a quand
même un sens pour pour le modem les
sénateurs modem actuellement ils sont
dans le groupe de l'union centriste
qu'on appelle le groupe union centriste
et c'est au sénat qui est un groupe qui
est allié avec les républicains est ce
que vous dites
ils doivent me laisse clairement aller
plutôt du côté du groupe de la majorité
faire une distinction entre les choses
il ya une majorité sénatoriale qui
soutiendra j'imagine
il a annoncé sa candidature la
candidature du président de l'arche et
dans cette majorité sénatoriale il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui par ailleurs
soutiennent la majorité présidentielle
je passe sur ce soit antinomiques
pour tout vous dire et donc il
appartiendra aux sénateurs modem comme à
tous ceux qui ont le sentiment je le
répète que nous oeuvrons dans la bonne
direction de s'identifier d'une façon ou
d'une autre soient dans leur groupe soit
par d'autres voies et moyens les cas je
suis ils verront ensemble et jean on en
parlera ensemble quand on les réunira ça
arrive à moi mon seul à seul sentiment
c'est qu'il faut dans cette assemblée
comme dans tout que ceux qui qui au fond
défendre la politique que nous menons et
je répète et pas besoin d'être
totalement alignée
puisse s'identifier alors après c'est à
eux et peut-être avec eux mais au fond
c'est une affaire plutôt partisane
qu'une affaire de groupe d'identifier
les choses le groupe uc est un groupe
très ancien dans l'institution
sénatoriales comme le groupe r d est ce
comme un certain nombre d'autres groupes
je comprends les équilibres qu'ils
trouvent à l'intérieur de leur groupe
donc je n'appartiens pas de rentrer dans
cette logique là il m'appartient pas
encore - communistes des relations avec
le parlement de rentrer dans cette
logique là mais il m'appartient
simplement de me direz de m'interroger
sur l'idée que comment on fait en sorte
que tous ces gens qui as ont été au
rendez vous des réformes ont été au
rendez vous du budget ont été au rendez
vous de la confiance quand la confiance
leur a été posée puisse identifier
puisse porter au sénat la voix de ceux
qui trouvent que tout ça va dans la
bonne direction quand bien même ils
pensent qu'il faut amender ou amodiés
telle ou telle disposition sachant que
sa stratégie la majorité c'est une
stratégie que vous avez l'intention de
développer pour les deux années à venir
l'idée c'est de rassembler autour de la
majorité présidentielle pour ensuite
aller au départemental aux régionales
la logique des choses gel avec une même
étiquette pardon de dire une chose assez
simple la logique des choses c'est ceux
qui s'identifient dans la politique
gouvernementale et qui partagent
l'essentiel de la politique menée et qui
pour l'essentiel d'ailleurs de ces
personnalités l' ont soutenu la
candidature du président de macron
puisse identifier ce soutien là mais
c'est important que cette logique là
elle s'incarne d'abord au sénat pour la
première fois dans la création d'un
nouveau lorsque c'est à noter vous ne
parliez du groupe et l'hérault aime le
changement de nom est aussi un signal de
la part du groupe et la brême pour dire
si cette logique notre volonté est une
volonté d'ouverture
le sénat est une maison du temps long je
le disais sur la question de la
législation il faut donner le temps aux
choses et tout ce qui force dans la vie
publique en tout cas c'est ma conception
personnelle n'est pas une bonne chose
que ce n'est pas des choses qui sont des
mouvements naturels ou sincère moi je
l'attends plutôt des mouvements naturels
et sains sitôt laisser les choses se
faire on verra ce que veulent les uns
les autres
je suis pas sûr que d'ailleurs que tous
les sénateurs modem ou qui sont proches
du modem disent exactement la même chose
donc il faut les laisser
il faut le laisser réfléchir eux mêmes
moi ma préoccupation comme membre de la
majorité commandes du gouvernement c'est
de faire en sorte que ceux qui
s'identifient dans la politique que nous
menons soit visible voilà c'est ça allez
on va parler des élus locaux jean castex
le premier ministre qui recevait
r les présidents de région il ya besoin
de renouer la confiance entre jean
castex et les présidents de région vous
étiez vous à matignon hier avec avec le
premier ministre je suis j'avais une
réunion après avec le 1er mai j'ai
croisé les présidents de région qui
avait l'air assez satisfait cette
rencontre moi je vais vous dire j'en ai
un peu assez qu'on dise il faut renouer
la confiance
d'abord la confiance non mais ça fait
trois ans qu'il me semble que alors
j'entends ce qu'on peut dire sur les
plateaux sur les tribunes je me souviens
du précédent quinquennat je n'étais
peser pas partie de cette majorité là ça
vous aurait échappé sinon plus de 13
milliards de baisses de dotations à
découpage des régions dont on pourrait
quand même douté de la pertinence
géographique culturelle économique et
dont on un certain nombre de régions
souffrent encore et les habitants des
régions jamais consulté jamais consulté
je pense à la région grand test je pense
à la région occitanie fin on a quand
même fait du découpage de région centre
de se demander quel était donc soyez
c'était la bretagne
j'aurais aimé d'être découpés et qui l'a
pas été mais n'est jamais consulté non
plus je vois bien le tropisme qui est le
vôtre mais je ne veux pas rentrer dans
ce débat breton parce que c'est un débat
douloureux depuis le début est assez
compliqué mais moi j'ai vu comme on a
maltraité j'étais élu local
j'étais maire président de pci et vous
n'avez pas vu sur les plateaux parce que
j'ai considéré qu'il fallait faire la
part du chemin et donc on a on a
organisé une petite ritournelle depuis
2010 est en dix ans maltraité
collectivités on a stabilisé les
dotations alors que nous avons une perte
de recettes historiques pour ce qui est
du budget de l'état on stabilise
toujours les dotations on augmente un
certain nombre de fonds la d6 la detr
enfin c'est des élus qui ne m'écouteront
reconnaîtront leurs petits si je peux
dire on met dans le plan de relance un
certain nombre d'éléments de
stabilisation la confiance se décrète
pas la confiance est aussi un état
d'esprit réciproque
il semble que du côté du gouvernement
nous avons fait un certain nombre de
gestes nous avons envoyé un certain
nombre de signaux alors dès lors qu'on
est un peu de bonne foi on devrait
pouvoir reconnaître quand même mais ils
le reconnaissent notamment sur cette
question du plan de relance a laissé
pour ça mais je vous le dis parce que
hier j'ai plutôt le sentiment que les
présidents de région quelle que soit
leur obédience
aucune d'entre elles ne me semble tout à
fait aligné sur la politique
gouvernementale ou sur la vision
gouvernementale reconnaissait que là
nous avions une démarche qui permettait
de construire les choses mais en
revanche il ya un problème ce qu'ils
disent aussi sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire est ce que là ça a été de
nature à relancer la méfiance est ce que
vous avez fait un faux pas sur la
gestion de cette crise n'ont alors pas
le d'abord tout le monde a fait face
dans tous les pays du monde à une crise
sanitaire que personne n'attendait qui a
fait irruption un peu comme un tsunami
et qui a débordé tout le monde parce que
voilà parce que personne ne l'avait vécu
la vérité c'est ça il ya pu y avoir des
difficultés sur les masses qui a pu y
avoir des difficultés sur un certain
nombre de sujets reconnaissons aussi
d'ailleurs les collectivités pour ceux
qui sont les plus intellectuellement
honnête on va dire reconnaissent que sur
la gestion de la sphère du chômage sur
la question de la préservation d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises sur la
question des prêts bancaires
on a quand même fait quelque chose qui
était totalement inédit à une vitesse
assez remarquable il faut saluer tous
les fonctionnaires de l'état en
particulier mais aussi les
fonctionnaires des collectivités qui se
sont mis en mouvement très vite pour
faire en sorte de colmater ce qu'il
fallait colmater de l' équilibre social
l équilibre économique alors que ça
n'ait pas été parfait certes il peut
arriver aussi que dans les collectivités
ce ne soit pas parfait tout ça moi
j'entends le nécessitent et d'évaluation
et de regarder après peut-être qui ce
qu'on a pu voir si c'était trop faut
toujours tirer les leçons d'une crise
mais ce qui s'est produit à marseille
vous parler des décisions récentes
moi je il ya un moment quand il ya des
décisions impopulaires je vois que le
chemin est en train d'être pris de la
difficulté c'est toujours difficile
d'endosser les décisions impopulaires
personne n'a envie de prendre des
décisions impopulaires il ya un moment
quand il faut prendre des décisions
impopulaires le premier ministre l'a
très bien dit bah on est obligé de
prendre ses responsabilités nous on
aimerait aussi pour voir dit aux
restaurateurs aux gens qui tiennent les
bas qu'on laisse ouvert venir en amont
et on n'est pas pervers au point d'avoir
un plaisir particulier à fermer des
établissements dont on sait qu'ils sont
en difficulté financière
simplement on considère nous à la place
qui est la nôtre que notre responsable
jeudi indique-t-on à la vue des
indicateurs à scolarise même les
établissements hospitaliers de marseille
qu'il faut qu'on stoppe parce qu'on ne
peut on ne peut pas se trouver dans la
situation où dans un mois on nous dirait
vous saviez et parce que vous n'avez pas
voulu être impopulaire vous avez laissé
faire
alors j'assume la part d'impopularité et
j'assume aussi enfin je comprends
parfaitement la colère et même pire que
la colère le désespoir d'un certain
nombre de gens qui commençaient à re
voir le bout du tunnel comme on dit et
qui disent on est reparti dans une crise
sanitaire mais
mais dans cette crise on a on doit faire
oeuvre de responsabilité et c'est
valable pour l'état nation c'est valable
pour l'état donc c'est valable aussi
pour les collectivités j'ai été maire il
m'est arrivé de prendre des décisions
impopulaires
parce que je considérais que c'était
l'intérêt de la collectivité et au fond
ça n'a pas empêché jeu soit réélu parce
que les gens reconnaissent quand vous
êtes solide et courageux dans les
décisions difficiles qu'il faut prendre
quand vous êtes élu local comme quand
vous êtes élu national est-ce que vous
pensez que ça c'est bien compris par les
français et que d'autres m'ont dit le
cas de marseille aix marseille serait un
cas un peu particulier pas forcément
parce que espèces mais c'est pas un
grief du tout que je fais aux français
parce que nous sommes tous contre le non
pas forcément parce que je sais et c'est
évidemment pas un grief que je fais aux
citoyens français parce que j'en suis un
comme les autres au fond c'est au fond
tant que l'émergence de la crise
c'est-à-dire les conséquences directes
qui sont des réanimations et les décès
n'apparaît pas on a du mal à qualifier
et à rendre la réalité des choses vers
ces petits boulots risque et donc c'est
difficile tant que le risque est pas aux
portes sauf que quand une fois qu'on
commence à voir monter très fortement
les réanimations et des décès on est
déjà dans une tendance qui fait que
pendant un mois on le voit apparaître ce
qu'on veut essayer d'éviter c'est ça et
donc je comprends parfaitement que la
perception des citoyens français que
nous sommes tous soit une situation
difficile parce que tant qu'on n'est pas
face au danger immédiat on a du mal à
croire que le danger arrive me croyez
moi si on prend ces décisions là c'est
qu'on est con on estime que la situation
est suffisamment sérieuse pour qu'on
puisse prendre des décisions graves et
sérieuses autre sujet marc raynaud c'est
la lutte contre les séparatismes sujet
auquel va s'attaquer le gouvernement
vous confirmer qu'un manuel mâcon
prendra la parole vendredi je vous le
confirme et c'est à ce moment là qu'on
ira au cours d'un déplacement et donc si
vous avez déjà ou non pas encore que le
texte arrivera qu'on parlement l'idée
c'est un dépôt de textes avant noël et
dans le premier semestre on est en train
de caler le calendrier mais c'est le
premier semestre que le texte a sur un
certain nombre de disposer là il ya des
registres qui relève plutôt de
l'application de la loi reste depuis des
années parfois
il ya des registres que relève du
réglementaire il ya du registre qui
relève du législatif mais il
appartiendra au président de la
république de donner le cap et après que
le texte viennent mettre en musique les
éléments législatifs viennent mettre en
musique ce que ce corps a dit le
président de la république sur ces
questions de séparatistes qui sont des
questions importantes qui sont des
questions qui traversent la société
française qu'il faut essayer de porter
avec lucidité parce que ceux qui disent
ça n'existe pas je crois qu'on vit pas
tout à fait dans le même monde et en
même temps sans volonté de
stigmatisation et sans volonté d'essayer
de deux de se servir de ça pour des
motifs politiques
en tout cas il faut faire en sorte
qu'elles puissent est applicable dans
ses fondements et ses principes et c'est
ce que dira le président et donc on va
attendre que le président s'exprime
vendredi pour en dire plus et applicable
sans forcément mais vous voyez bien que
ya la loi de 1905 et poser des principes
dans le cadre de ce qu'était 1905
c'était il ya cent quinze ans il ya des
choses qui ont évolué et donc c'est ça
qu'il faut regarder
une dernière question sur les régionales
est ce que est ce que tout report toute
idée de report des élections régionales
est écarté aujourd'hui le premier
ministre il a été interrogé lors de la
rencontre avec les chefs de partis et
les chefs de groupe
les présidents et présidentes de groupe
à l'assemblée et au sénat il a dit que
la volonté c'était de tenir les
élections en mars mais on n'a toujours
pas de date
oui j'ai vu un responsable en
l'occurrence monsieur fort qu'il faisait
grief au gouvernement de ne pas avoir
précisé la date on n'aura plus
simplement que la dernière fois lors des
précédentes élections régionales
quatre mois avant c'est seulement à ce
moment-là bon c'est la règle c'est de ne
nous faisons pas de ne cherchons pas des
loups là où il y en a pas évidemment la
menace sanitaire pose une question c'est
là les conditions et donc je crois qu'il
aura des travaux qui seront menés avec
le ministère de l'intérieur pour
regarder les conditions dans lesquelles
peut s'exercer quand même une élection
c'est pas seulement jour du vote
on se souvient des épisodes de mars et
de juin une élection c'est aussi la
capacité à faire campagne qu'il faut
regarder dans les conditions sanitaires
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
éventuellement est anticipée ou un
reflux ou quelque chose qui serait plus
sérieux encore dans les mois qui
viennent pour regarder comment pourrait
se dérouler les élections en tout cas
sur la table l'idée c'est évidemment de
maintenir la date qui est telle qu'elle
est prévue après vous savez sur ce virus
ont appris à être prudents et à dire
qu'il ya des choses que nous ne savons
pas comme la plupart des pays du monde
ne savent pas faire comme tous les pays
du monde ne savent pas d'air mais
je vous aime avait déjà interrogé c'est
bien entendu votre chance d'une demande
de très claire du président de la
république
absolument cacher pas va trouver non
mais c'est d'abord une affaire
collective parce que tu c'est une
campagne même si ses treize régions
métropolitaines une question de
dynamique nationale j'ai été élue
régionale j'ai fait des campagnes
régionales je m'intéresse c'est que vous
avez pris celle du coup c'est n'est pas
ce n'est pas une nouveauté que je
m'intéresse aux régionales et quand
j'aurai pris la décision
moi je viendrai vous voir dressés à la
prochaine merci stéphane on regarde la
une de ouest france ce matin l'éclatante
économique du jeu vidéo c'est à la une
de ouest france merci beaucoup je
m'arrête avec n'ont pas de soutien aux
clubs les territoires